karema silly and his wife are one of the
many families desperately searching for
news of their loved one they last heard
from their uncle Hashem Raman at 3 a.m.
on the day of the fire someone will see
something - also if you see them please
get in contact myself so I think
although the family okay
things I'm sorry as well with little
information they're doing everything in
their power to try and find him stopping
everyone they think might help this
money to that point
would you be able to put up somewhere
yeah Austin Austin Seminole be ok she
must make you very much thank you
they're not letting anybody in the
hospital while Kareem pounds the
pavement looking for answers other
family members have been searching
hospitals so Ankur basically said that
he's gone to Chelsea must miss the
hospital he's been in there they've
identified all of the people that have
come from the Grantham towers and my
uncle wasn't one of them
so he's now making his way to the next
hospital he said sent Mary's Hospital
she's gonna go there next and see what
happens
creams uncle is diabetic and called the
family on the night of the fire to
reassure them don't worry mum soon as
I'm out I'll let you know
I'm going to be said to as soon as I'm
out I'll let you know police are coming
to get me I've spoken to them it's going
to be okay and then that was it
this is also a very a very big football
community so we all used to play
football together you know and some
friends lived in rental towers some
physics in the towers next to it some
friends lived in the flat below so you
everyone a meeting is even knows of
someone that's missing or know someone
that lives there or trying to look for
someone getting more impatient Kareem
wants answers hello my friend hi guys
first of all thank you for everything we
appreciate all of your help in that your
work has been amazing and my uncle lives
or lived in the 20th floor in the
ground-floor Tower we're not sure if you
made it out I just wanted to get some
feedback from I know you can't tell me a
lot but but is getting nothing I don't
want to tell me anything at his
grandmother's home just meters from the
tower the family gather an island freeze
and hospital unconscious and they just
can't identify him because he's got no
idea of something oh yeah Jamie and I
have yeah well preparing for the worst
of course you know we have to understand
that but there is still hope and we want
to keep on for that hope we don't want
to let go of that hope until it's
confirmed you know and up until that
moment we're going to keep looking
Charlotte Lomas Sky News